notre série de portraits de la
génération 20 ans dans les années 2020
aujourd'hui un jeune pompier volontaire
côte-d'oriens emmanuelle haïm cette
vocation tout jeune et il a déjà une
idée bien précise de son futur chemin il
s'est confié à bombay et rodolfo gier
c'est dieu c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2009 c'est tout
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle emmanuel bailly
j'ai 19 ans je suis sapeur pompier
volontaire depuis trois ans à la caserne
de selongey en côte d'or
on
on va venir trouver levé savez c'est
l'ambulance le véhicule qu'on utilise le
plus souvent qui sert pour le secours à
personne du coup on y monter dans le
camion n'est parti sur la commune donc
on est arrivé à une personne qui a eu un
accident au niveau de son travail
donc nous on réalise les actions qu'on
qui sont à faire désinfecter la plaie on
fait les gestes de premiers secours on
reste avec la victime aura sur la
victime et on reste auprès d'elle
pendant le transport jusqu'à l'hôpital
[Musique]
cette démission qui sont variés ils
travaillent ensemble avec d'autres
collègues c'est vraiment il ya plein de
plein de qualités qui sont requises qui
sont mises ensemble et qui font que ben
non à ce métier qui est vraiment
plaisant
sinon une intervention qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est le premier décès qu'on fait
c'est toujours toujours marquant parce
qu'on n'est pas habitué dans la vie de
tous les jours avoir des personnes
décédées voilà le soir on y repense on
revoit les images et donc celles ci on
s'en souvient vraiment il faut garder
notre carapace comme on dit et est resté
fort rester solide et ne pas ne pas
tomber forcément dans la tristesse ou
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé à vouloir devenir pompier
quand j'avais 11 ans
j'entrais en sixième j'ai vu une affiche
de la section dans la rue comme ça et
j'ai dit à un acte dit pourquoi pas
essayer je me suis inscrit le coup
niveau études de moi j'ai fait une
seconde générale ensuite jugé déboucher
sur un bac stg en management et gestion
a toujours une petite crainte enfin avec
voilà et puis c'est vrai qu'on est
toujours content de le voir rentrer
quand il re franchit la porte
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui lui tient
vraiment à coeur et des personnes quand
c'est vrai que quand il part en tint en
inter il est toujours excité il est
toujours voilà un vrai gamin quoi
passionner pas la formule 1 donc
j'aime beaucoup jouer au jeu de formule
1 sur la console ça peut être aussi
divers jeux parce que je suis vraiment
passionné par l'automobile en règle
générale j'ai un petit groupe d'amies on
est 4 5
j'en ai quelques-uns que je vois de
temps à autre sinon je fais également du
basket donc on s'entraîne en fait un
petit un petit un petit match le samedi
matin sur sur dijon et c'est difficile
d'avoir 20 ans c'est difficile d'avoir
40 ans c'est difficile d'avoir tous les
ânes un petit peu parce que chacun est
impactée à son niveau mais nous on est
impactée surtout au niveau de nos amis
nos contacts sociaux parce qu'on aime
beaucoup sortir on aime s'amuser mais je
pense qu'il faut savoir s'adapter
profiter au maximum
dans 20 ans je me vois toujours avec
cette tenue l'art évidemment mais je me
vois
exercer ce métier dans la ville de
monaco il y en a qui aiment les pompiers
de paris y en a qui aiment les marins
pompiers de marseille - c c'est le corps
des sapeurs pompiers de monaco qui
m'intéresse donc s'ils n'en attends je
peux y accéder ce serait un peu le rêve
ultime